nachdem corona skandal in der
fleischfabrik tönnies ist die zahl der
nachweis infizierten im kreis gütersloh
weiter gestiegen der wunsch nach dem
negativ test ist daher umso größer vor
allem weil ab montag in
nordrhein-westfalen die sommerferien
beginnen anfang der woche eröffnete
dafür eine corona teststation bild
berichtete darüber doch die reicht nun
mittlerweile nicht mehr aus unser bild
reporter michael engelberg ist seit
tagen in der region vor ort und weiß
bescheid über die neuesten entwicklungen
michael was hat man jetzt im zuge dieses
großen andrangs für diese corona
teststation getan
wir stehen hier vor dem werk von clemens
tönnies also man hat wohl eingesehen
dass ist sehr ambitioniert war über
nacht ein testzentrum in der innenstadt
von gütersloh aus dem boden zu stampfen
das wird geführt von der
kassenärztlichen vereinigung das muss
man sich so vorstellen der sämtliche
ärzte aus dem münsterland und aus dem
kreis warendorf dem kreis gütersloh dort
zusammenarbeiten die testung vornehm
natürlich in abwechselnden schichten man
aber nur 100 leute pro stunde testen
kann
und gestern sind die ersten ergebnisse
vorgelegt worden 230 leute wurden
getestet und 230 negativ
nichtsdestotrotz hat der kreis 6 640
1000 personen und ganz viele von denen
wollen jetzt in urlaub und man hat
eingesehen dass eine teststation alleine
nicht reicht in rheda wiedenbrück soll
jetzt morgen oder eventuell heute schon
eine nächste station eröffnet werden und
es soll auch noch eine dritte station
eröffnet werden grund ist die person
diese die einen negativen test vorweisen
können die dürfen halt auch ihren urlaub
so verbringen dieses wollen es gibt ja
länder wie schleswig holstein die da den
riegel vorgeschoben haben und auch wie
die stadt münster die von hier vom kreis
gütersloh oder von rheda wiedenbrück wo
ich jetzt hier stehen eine knappe auto
stunde entfernt sind dort davon zum
beispiel nur mit mund nase maske sich
überhaupt in die stadt begeben und dort
bewegen
michael wie ist denn die stimmung in den
warteschlangen ich kann mir vorstellen
dass die leute einerseits genervt sind
aber auch so ein bisschen ja
unsicher ob das ergebnis positiv negativ
und damit ja auch ihre urlaubsplanung
werden kann
also die leute sind natürlich schon ein
bisschen angespannt weil von diesem
ergebnis dann wirklich eine ganze menge
abhängen es gab jetzt knapp dreieinhalb
monate extremst harte auflagen dass man
sich möglichst ja schon aus dem haus
bewegt aber kontakt beschränkungen
vorlagen und jetzt sieht man seit zwei
wochen wieder licht am ende des tunnels
und dann kommt der chor ohne ausbruch
hier beim fleisch riesen tennis und
deshalb sind die leute natürlich ein
bisschen angespannt die wollen natürlich
jetzt nicht wieder die nächsten 14 tage
in ihrer in ihrer bude verbringen oder
sich kaum mit leuten treffen die wollen
einfach in urlaub weil einfach die
letzten dreieinhalb monate auch sehr
sehr viel kraft gekostet haben und
deshalb ist der andrang natürlich so
groß und nicht nur nicht nur die angst
und nicht in urlaub zu fahren ist
bedingt dass die leute sich testen
lassen sondern sie wollen einfach
sichergehen dass sie bislang gesund sind
und deshalb kann man nur empfehlen die
kontakt beschränkungen einzuhalten den
abstand zu wahren sich die hände
vernünftig zu waschen zu desinfizieren
und nasenschutz zu tragen und die korona
app zu installieren sich testen zu
lassen und dann geht's ab in den urlaub
michael engelberg vielen dank für den
moment aus rheda wiedenbrück